dans deux semaines au festival d'été de
québec
les spectateurs sur les plaines
d'abraham n'auront à nouveau qu'un seul
choix d'hyères la coors light un
canettes et rien d'autre et si presque
partout pareil dans les autres grands
festivals du québec
les brasseries commercial exige un
monopole en échange d'une importante
commandite la blonde cabral la bière
officielle de la fête nationale
mais voilà que les organisateurs de la
saint-jean-baptiste décide d'aller à
contre-courant
ils ont demandé à 9 microbrasserie de
québec de préparer une bière spécifique
pour la fête nationale au même prix que
la bière commercial bertrand lemoine a
participé à l'élaboration de la recette
j'entends beaucoup de enfin des gens qui
disent non non ça fait du bien de voir
les micros sont sur les plaines qui
enfin d'avoir une vierge
je dis bon centre unis mais sans vouloir
dénigrer personnes le collectif a brassé
quinze mille litres de bière en fût il y
a aussi des cannettes pour la vente au
détail et ya pas si longtemps ne disait
pas ça peut pas être possible de faire
ça pour la fête nationale est
vraisemblable massaly c'est le cas cette
année
la décision d'un de ne pas recourir une
cro brasserie je pense que c'est surtout
assez sûr de l'incompréhension en 2017
les organisateurs de la fête nationale
ont coupé les ponts avec la brasserie
labatt
c'est quand même une commande et de
quelques milliers de dollars que on a dû
se priver
par contre je nous croyons forte 500
moins fortement qu on va récupérer ces
sommes en vendant plus de bien
le risque c'est qu'en cas de pluie les
ventes de bière chute et l'organisation
risque de faire des déficits mais les
neuf microbrasserie se sont engagés à
racheter les surplus de la blonde
d'abraham pour ensuite les écouler dans
leur établissement au festival d'été de
québec on exclut toute association avec
les microbrasseries le regroupement des
grands événements de son côté explique
que globalement les festivals dépendent
grandement des ventes d'alcool et des
grosses commandites des brasseurs
les ventes de bière et d'aliments ça
représente 8 % en moyenne des revenus
des événements membres du rémi donc
c'est comparable aux subventions du
gouvernement du québec
d'importants profits qui sont réinvestis
dans la programmation assure le festival
ici pascal point la radio canada québec